nominated tonight how you feeling I'm
feeling really great you know other than
the Kobe hearing the Kobe News other
than that you know it's it was most
definitely said to be a powerful night
for us it felt like everything changed
of course the second that we all heard
that and I feel like everyone's stomach
straps where were you and how did you
find out I was actually at my hotel room
get dressed and uh somebody got a call
in you know they said it and I looked at
him like you know before you even repeat
something like that you better really
know where that's coming from and you
actually reconfirmed in it and I just
stopped what I was doing for a minute he
said no it didn't feel real it didn't
feel real um I don't know if you knew
him at all I had you in met him over the
years I met him I came across him a
couple of times he was always a real
cool dude you know he always showed me
love and it was always genuine you know
I was a fan of his game and you know
he's real unfortunately I know that's
gonna be a topic of conversation for
everybody tonight you know it's hard
it's this horrible thing happens so many
people knew him but we are still here at
the Grammys how do you think you'll
approach it should you win tonight how
will that feel I mean I feel being a
true champion you you really want to
always have your history celebrated so
if I was the winning I'm sure anybody
else who went we got to celebrate Kobe's
history and that's what I think the true
champion
thank you we're just starting off 2020
is there anything musically you want to
accomplish this year what's next for you
I'm excited about seeing my label
Maybach music release a new body of work
together with all of the body parts and
all the members it's going to be real
powerful and we have a lot in the way
inspiration
[Music]